tell me for me a person who's been
[ __ ] on my deals and a person has
friends that never figured out how to
make shoes with a German company that
couldn't tell me to wear a BLM shirt and
take off my red hat like what would have
happened if I was at Nike right
um
uh tell me exactly how to engineer the
situation I'm gonna tell you exactly how
you got a big voice have the balls as a
man to call out the individuals don't
call them Jews call them by their name
and start a war against those
individuals they're not Jewish but if
that's the case
will you help me with that sure okay 100
[ __ ] are asking well let me like
flip that too I don't understand the
industry well I I I see that people are
[ __ ] people over for sure but how do
you solve that if you run if you right
now run the world's uh you're doing a
million things but say you ran also a
record label
I have ran a record like well I've been
ran by a record label where I was the
face of a record label and had Big Sean
of different people complaining to me
and I knew [ __ ] about running a record
label I was simply just a talented
producer and an influencer yes that then
started good music but I wasn't the one
running good music how would you do it
differently this is something I I
propose I would look at
the top 10 execs and three fields in
sports
uh film and music
and I would look at the top 10
uh clients participants act talent I
would look at the top talent in each of
those field the top 10 of them and some
of them are going to be Tom Brady some
of them are going to be Taylor Swift
some of them they're not all going to be
black right some of them so
uh some of them would be Adele right uh
and
will look at all their contracts
transparently and we'll compare the
notes and re-engineer like it's a new
constitution because when I told my dad
when I was 19 I was going to get into
the music industry he begged me not to
he said I heard it's treacherous
now I'm in a position where I've been
through it I saw it I went out made some
money somewhere else I saw my name get
smeared I saw my family get destroyed I
saw my reputation get destroyed and I'm
back here to have this kind of I'm back
here as a being with engineering
opportunities so I would say if you say
as a shitty apology what is the version
uh of the apology short of kissing
Howard Stern's dick
I don't think anyone wants to kiss
flowers that's the point Howard Stern
nobody wants to kiss your dick so shut
the [ __ ] up I said by the way I'm
antagonizing Howard Stern I used to be a
fan of you
yeah me too yeah not still a fan and
sometimes not now you're just doing
click bait like everybody else
now you're just a sad old man Howard all
right
now Howard Stern this is the first time
anyone's said your name in years your
own family doesn't say your name unless
they're calling to get their bills paid
you're going hard
see that's beautiful right there that's
much better than calling Jewish media
call go after individuals okay so after
individuals and you don't talk [ __ ]
about me talk [ __ ] about me this is
great and you know what that is yeah
what's that
engineering that's an engineer's
approach yeah Engineers yeah yeah you
should learn some of that